معنى دكتور مي الكيلو وزيره الصحه
الفلسطينيه دكتوره اهلا بك كيف تصفين اذن
المشهد هذا الصباح
مدينه جنين ومخيم جنين حيث الوضع حار جدا
في الدخل المخيم وايضا في المدينه
الى الان هناك الشهداء واحد نحن الشهداء
وصل الى مستشفى
جنين الحكومي والاخر وصل الى مستشفى
الى احدى المستشفيات هناك
مستشفى
جميل
يعني جزء منها لكن لم
يحصل عليها لان العمليه القائمه همم
في جنين كما قلت في رابع حرج للغايه همم
بلغنا من الهلال الاحمر بوجود عديده همم
موجوده
في الشوارع ويصعب انقاذها واخلاقها حتى
الان همم لان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يعق
مركبات الاسعاف الى داخل المخيم لانقاذ
الجرحى وهذا يتنافى مع اقل مع مع ادنى ال
ال ال
المفاهيم الانسانيه والمعاهدات الدوليه
بهذا الخصوص
بعض المركبات الاسعاف دخلت بس بطرق ملتويه
الى المخيم لكن تواجهها ايضا همم
اسرائيل بتحاول همم
سيارات اسعاف بطرق ملتويه هذا ما يبرر
ربما رد فعل قوات الاحتلال به الاستهلاف
هذه السيارات
لا لا يوجد الى الاحتلال سيارات اسعاف هذا
محرم دوليه حسب اتفاقيه
الدوليه نقيه جنوب الرابعه والترقيه جنوب
الثالثه وملحقاتها الجريح يجب ان يتلقى
العلاج وسيارات الاسعاف الهلال الاحمر يجب
ان تدخل في كافه الاماكن ويجب ان تكون
مامونه ولا تحتاج الى اذن من الصليب
الاحمر او من الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للدخلها
لكن اسرائيل التي تتصرف وكانها الازهر في
هذا العالم تعمل
فيها العالم في كافه العالم العالم
وبالتالي ليس بالحق اثنين ولا يوجد ايضا
حق اسرائيل ان ان تستهدف المجتمع المدني
الفلسطيني ولا ولا سيارات الاسعاف همم
يعني غير مقبول اي مبرر لاسرائيل في هذا
الموضوع
ايضا احمد
مستشفى جنين الحكومي قبل نصف ساعه واطلقت
بشكل متعمد الغاز
قسم الاطفال وكمان
امهات اخذت اطفالها وهربت ايضا هذا ياتي
ضمن همم ضمن المحرمات دوليه ضد القانون
الدولي وقانون الدولي الانساني
بالغاز ولي المرضى بشكل مباشر هل هذا امر
اعتيادي من قبل
قوات الاحتلال
فوق القانون ولا يوجد رد عليها وبالتالي
انا
في هذا اليوم همم دعيت الى اجتماع عاجل مع
الصليب الاحمر الدولي ليقف عندما هل هو
منظمه الصحه العالميه لانه اذا بدنا
نتعامل مع القضايا الانسانيه على الاقل ان
يتعاملوا مع الحواسم للجرح بالتعافي وان
لا يكون هناك استهداف للمؤسسات
الصحيه سواء كانت حكوميه او غيرها وسواء
كانت متحركه هذا يقع
فعلا بالمخانه همم
فاين مجتمع الدولي ومن من هذه المنصه وادي
المؤسسات الحقوقيه والمجتمع الدولي
والصحيه بدون روت التحرك الفوري العادي
الممارسات العنصليه الاسرائيليه التي يقوم
بها الجيش الاحتلال الان في جنين همم لا
يمكن ان نقبل
يبقى مكتوب في الايدي امام ما يجري بمصدر
الدوري اجراءات
طيب
يعني احنا مش انا حاليا عندي غرفه عمليات
في دخله وزاره الصحه لكن سننتقل الى اكيد
في غرفه عمليات
سياسيه بهذا السياق واكيد راح تكون همم
متخصصه بهذا الموضوع اكيد يعني راح يكون
متوجهين الى المستند الدولي بكل تاكيد
لانه لا نستطيع ان نبقى كما نحن ولا يجب
ان يكون هناك همم
صفه المتفرجه المجتمع الدولي وايضا دول
الاقليم واخوتنا الاشقاء والعرب اتجاه ما
يحضر في الدنيا اشكرك يا دكتوره كنت معنا
من رام الله دكتور ايضا ميله وزيره الصحه
الفلسطينيه من الجليل هذه